hello and welcome to luminex's
coronavirus virtual webinar
today we are going to talk to you about
luminex's flexible solutions for sars
cov2 detection
we have a number of topics and
information to share with you today
as you can see here in our agenda
but first let me start with some
introductions
i'm sheri dunbar and i'm the senior
director of global scientific
affairs for luminex
and i'm very happy to be speaking with
you today
i'd also like to introduce my co-speaker
dr aaron benfield who is the senior
director of molecular applications for
luminex
to begin let's recap the events that
have transpired over the last
six months and have brought us to where
we are today we know that many
coronaviruses
can cause common cold respiratory
illnesses
but others like the first sars
coronavirus and the mayor's coronavirus
that followed several years later
can cause very severe disease in
december of 2019
we heard of the first reports of a novel
coronavirus
of zoonotic origin that was causing
pneumonia in the wuhan
province of china the virus
now known as sars cov2 causes the
illness designated covid19
and it has spread rapidly across the
globe
by may 2020 5.7 million people
had been diagnosed with covet 19 and
over 350 000
had died and in the united states
over 1.7 million cases have been
identified
with more than 100 and 1 000 deaths
by the end of may u.s and global cases
have continued to rise
in the week since these data were
reported and also we do see some
evidence of flattening the curve
in various locations
now let me review some of the quick
facts about the illness
the incubation period for covid19 is
thought to extend to 14 days
hence the recommendation to self
quarantine for 14 days after
exposure however the median time to the
onset of symptoms is thought to be
approximately 4 to 5 days the most
common symptoms are fever dry cough
and fatigue but there can be a wide
spectrum of symptoms
including aches and pains nasal
congestion
headache sore throat even diarrhea and
the loss of taste and smell is
reportedly
quite common everyone is at risk for
infection
but the majority of individuals will
have only mild to moderate symptoms
but those with underlying medical
conditions the elderly
and the immunocompromised are more
likely to have serious illness
and the fatality rate is highest in the
immunocompromise and those 65
and older so what can we do to combat
this pandemic
first we need to have rapid diagnostic
solutions
so that we can enact effective infection
control
and isolation protocols we need to be
able to perform
epidemiological monitoring and zero
surveillance in the community
so that we can implement specific health
policies to try and prevent the spread
but ultimately we need to have effective
drugs to treat the illness
and an effective vaccine for
immunization against
sars kobe 2.
so where does luminex fit in this
picture well it's in the rapid diagnosis
category
luminex is a provider of flexible
molecular testing solutions for the
diagnosis of infectious diseases
we understand that labs come in all
shapes and sizes
and there is no one-size-fits-all so to
address the needs of various laboratory
settings we have both
targeted tests and broader syndromic
panels
and these are available in multiple
formats our sample to answer solutions
that fit into the moderate complexity
laboratory
are available on our aries and verigene
platform
and the more high throughput options for
the high complexity lab
are based on our xmap speed array
technology
and run on the magpix and luminex 200
platforms
our diagnostic tests are focused in four
major
areas of infection respiratory
gastrointestinal
women's health and health care acquired
infections
and we also have some molecular tests
for genetic
diseases
in response to the covid19 pandemic
luminex was able to rapidly develop and
deploy
two sars co-v2 molecular assays
that have received emergency use
authorization by the fda
the next tag code v2 extended panel
runs on our magpix instrument and the
aries sarge kovi 2 assay runs on our
sample to answer aries
platform now i'd like to turn it over to
aaron who will describe each of these
assays in detail
and share some data on the clinical and
analytical performance
aaron take it away thank you thank you
sherry
so up first i will be discussing the
next tag code the extended panel
this targets the sars cobia ii
via the orf 1ab in an e gene
it's very high complex or it's very high
throughput and can do up to 96 samples
at a time it's very cost effective but
it's also highly complex
this is developed for our magpix system
it also requires nucleic acid extraction
up front
the preferred sample type is the
nasopharyngeal swab
it can be run as a stand-alone test or
alongside
our next tag respiratory pathogen panel
on the same plate
the total turnaround time including the
extraction step
is at four hours
as far as the workflow goes is initially
you have to do
nucleic acid extraction and
following nucleic acid extraction
approximately 5 35 microliters are
pipetted into
a plate you can do
up to 96 samples at a time or as little
as
one sample plus a couple of controls
the way this is pipetted is you're
aspirating 35 microns from your extract
and piercing a foil well mixing up and
down
and then refilling it with a foil seal
this is then placed on a thermocycler
and where it thermocycles for about
approximately two and a half
hours and then finally analyzed on the
magpix the magtix read takes
about 30 to 45 minutes for a full plate
when we did our limited detection
studies with the next tag cov panel
the only thing available to us at that
time was purified
genomic
material from an activated virus so this
was simply
spiked into negative patient utm
extracted and then run through the
entire system
in order for us to show limited
detection of any assay we
need to be able to show it can pick up
that concentration
at least 19 out of 20 times this table
just depicts
different levels of lod and what we saw
as well as the raw signal
in in the form of mbd for the three
different genes
the limited detection was established at
5 000 genomic equivalents
per mil again this was using purified
viral genomic material since then
it's been able we've been able to secure
some inactivated virus
and it is our thought that we can go
lower it's just not what we can
con or claim in the pi at this time
um we've also did some in silico
inclusivity
analysis uh which include 177 sequences
of the orf1ab gene
188 sequences of the engine 176
different sequences of the e gene we
were able to show that we had over 95
homology to all analyze sequences we're
also
able to show that the logo set for
in gene was over 95
homologous to all but six recently
submitted sequences
to the gene database as far as the
ancillico
cross reactivity analysis goes we
were able to show over 80 percent
homology with a few pathogens are listed
here
mycobacterium tuberculosis legionella as
well as
pseudomonas um in sars or stars one
however no anticipated implications are
detected of these non-target organisms
um as is expected
the other assay i would like to cover is
the aries sars covi
assay that is also emergency use
authorized by the fda
it targets the 1av and engines
it's moderately complex it's got
moderate
throughput and allows you to run one and
up to 12
samples per instrument per batch so some
of our customers run
two samples that come into the lab they
just run those two
others they can you can run up to 12 per
instrument
it is a closed system which reduces the
potential for contamination
its preferred sample type is also nasal
pharyngeal swabs it has minimal hands-on
time
and the total turnaround time is
approximately two hours
here's a close-up of what an aries
cassette looks like
you'll notice that has some information
within a sticker as well as a barcode
the barcode enables the instrument
to identify the cassette the assay type
the lot number the expiration date and
so on
on the back you the only cassette
preparation step is to peel off a foil
still prior to the loading sample
now just looking a little closer at the
workflow
you simply prepare the cassette and add
200 microliters of utm
or equivalent close to sample two
then you load that cassette into a
magazine which fits up to six samples at
a time
then that magazine is loaded onto an
instrument
and finally the instrument will run and
automatically
result out each sample
this can be done either through an lx
interface or
manually
we also did very similar experiments to
determine the limit of detection for the
aries
covi ua assay
in this case um you know we just did
several dilutions
and then determined what concentration
of the material we could pick up 19 out
of 20 times this was
performed initially with purified
genomic
material and then subsequently
performed with real intact and activated
virus
and that's what we have presented here
on this next slide
the lod was determined at 333 genomic
equivalents for aries again
using an activated full intact virus
we also did in silico inclusivity and
cross reactivity analysis
that inclusivity analysis included
177 sequences of orf1ad and 188
sequences
in the in gene we had 100 homology
compared to our primers and those
sequences analyzed in the database
as far as cross reactivity analysis goes
we only observed any the sars
one or sars chronovirus with over 80
homology to our primers there's no
anticipated
amplification or detection of any
organism that isn't targeted
by the sars cov2 assay
i'm gonna take a step uh back and just
provide a quick
overview of how the molecular
applications assist customers in their
implementation process
the first thing we do is we will contact
a customer
have a phone call one to two weeks
before we're on site
to just understand what the needs are of
the lab namely their desired go live
date any kind of training that's needed
uh different shifts or multiple people
understanding how long that will take
and how many days
that's spread open understanding any
kind of verification
study assistance they need as well as
clinical education needs
we then will send a molecular
application specialist
for on-site training they will provide
unlimited number of staff
a limited number of training to staff
our days or shifts we do provide an
asset instrument and software overview
from you know sample to result is what
we want to set people up with
we are able to provide verification
support in most
instances for example we do have a
sample bank that support
most of our fda cleared applications out
there
we unfortunately do not have samples for
the
coronavirus applications but these
samples can be obtained from other
laboratories or your own lab
when we are on site we can review a
verification study plan
we also have template and other tools if
the laboratory needs it
we also have an it implementation
manager whose sole job is to provide
it and las support um he can
go on site or or you mainly assist
people with the
las orders build making the tests
reportable and orderable as well as
interfacing those results working with
the laboratory as well as third-party ls
vendors
lastly as part of the implementation
piece we have some clinical
education specialists who can
perform physician education where needed
now i'd like to turn it back over to
sherry to
conclude our talk
thank you aaron so in closing i would
like to thank all of you for joining
us today and i also want to let you know
where you can get more information
about luminex's flexible solutions for
sars co v2 detection and
everything else i want to make sure that
you
see the latest articles and product
information that's available on our
website
as shown by the links here we have a few
articles about
uh implementation of the aries sars code
v2 assay
in a variety of laboratories around the
world
we also have product sheets available
for both aries
and next tag we also have this
information available on
all level websites for our global
offices around the world
and be sure to visit our virtual booth
right here at the lab roots coronavirus
virtual webinar
here we have a list of the references
that were used for the preparation of
this presentation today
if you're interested in further
information you can also check those out
and then with that i would just like to
say thank you and we are available to
take any questions you have